で これから発言者まあ省略しますけど
ありのままに情報を発信していますか？それで私は文句言ってますけど
私が言ってること理解してないでしょうと
人に文句言う前に 私が正しい情報を発信
発信しましたね 発信しましたかね
それ問題です 発言者 発言者にも受信者同様
感情とフィルターの問題があります
問題はこの発言する人にいたっても感情とフィルターがあるんです
発信する情報は常に主観で合成しているんです
だから情報じゃないんですよ
自分で合成したものなんです
自分の都合という液体で情報を練っているんです
それは他人にとってはます受け入れにくいものになります
自分の都合で練ったものは入らないんですよ
受け入れないんです 拒否するのです
わからないでしょ 皆様
コンビニで買ったおにぎりをね
2つ買ってもう一人友達に
はい どうぞと言ったら受け取るでしょ
何も練ってないんです
で 自分がそうじゃなくて
おにぎり一つ開けて おにぎり
海苔もつけておいて ちょっと食べてみて
あ これだけ美味しい はい
どうぞとあげてみてください
受け取るもの 受け取りませんね
だから自分のフィルターで
もう感情でそこでめっちゃうと
もう情報っていうのは気持ち悪くて他人にとっては入らないんですよ
しかし 人が発信する情報
すべてそういう風に都合という液体で練っているのです
はい それから自分の都合ということを勉強しましょう
相手を自分の好みによって変える目的で情報を与えるのです
我々はなんで喋りますかというと
相手を自分の目的に変えたいのです
素直に受け取るなら受け入れられない
受け入れられないので
話術 ご褒美 約束などになどのにじゃないんです
さらに乗せて情報を与える
だから私が練ったものをね
気持ち悪くて受け入れないでしょう
しかし これ食べて私のものになってほしいんです
相手に ですから いろいろ皿に乗せるんですね
一つは実質 あるいはいろいろご褒美があったりしてね
あんたもう試験勉強すれば
もうどこかに連れて行くわ
ディズニーランド連れて行ってしまっとこうかね
そういうご褒美があると
やっぱりなんでしょうかと兼ねて結構です
じゃあお母さんディズニー連れてくる
じゃあ今度の試験でまあ 100点満点取らなくちゃいかん
と 95点でも取らなくちゃいかん
じゃあ頑張りますと言うでしょう
あれ ご褒美のせいなんです
それからいろいろ我々約束こと多いでしょ
ちゃんと勉強して大学なんか出たら
まあいい仕事がありますよとか
その約束にやられたってみんな大学に入って
ただ時間だけ過ごす 何も勉強しないということにないかい
で 勉強したら中の知らないぞと言われると
真面目に勉強するんです
会社はとにかく大学卒業してくださいって言ってるだけだからね
大学で UFO を研究したってもいいんです
お化けの体重を研究したってもいいんです
だからどれくらいでオバケは今見つからなかったんだから
まあ結果はゼロやと それでもいいんですね
日本の会社にはとにかく大学を卒業する
だからみんな若者は勉強はしないで
ただ 4 年間なんとか足踏みをしてますね
とにかくその場合で でも嫌ですから
こんなことやればいいでしょうに
やっぱり約束とかいろいろありますね
また 騙し 脅し 脅迫 マインドコントロールなどの皿もあるんです
だから我々は情報をちゃんと日本の和食と同じく立派な器に入れて提供するんです
その情報の器って何なのかというと
決して日本の陶器みたいな有名な誰が作ったものではなくて
脅しとか脅迫とかマインドコントロールとか
騙しとか話術とか そういうものなんです
コミュニケーションは強い者の勝ち方ですから
世の中で我々コミュニケーション
コミュニケーションで偉そうに言うのは
単純に強い者の勝ちだけの話です
コミュニケーションじゃないんです
話術はうまい人が言うことは聞く
騙し上手 人の話には誰でも乗るだけのことです
コミュニケーションの成り立ってないんです
だから成り立っ...成立しないコミュニケーションなんです
都合で発信するので 情報にはバイアスが入る
時間になったら言っていただくとすぐ終えます
他人が自分の都合で語っているという事実は
皆何度でも知っているので
他人の話には警戒心を持っている
無性に失敗することにも関わらずです
で 我々はどうしても人の話に警戒心を持ってるでしょ
しかし 乗るんですよ 警戒心持っちゃえばいいのに
すぐ俺ですと言ったら
なんで何がなったの？とすぐ聞くんです
俺って誰ですか？と聞かないんです
だからまあ この振り込め事件で巻き込まれる人も警戒心は持ってますよ
人の話に乗るんじゃないよと言いつつも乗ってしまうんです
受ける側も自分の都合で受けるので
話したものと理解したもののバージョンがかなり違います
そこで人が話したバージョンと私が理解したバージョンというバージョン 2つなんです
だからコミュニケーションが成り立たないんです
で 例えば私は子供に何か空飛ぶ絨毯の話をする
小人のおじいさんの話でもいいんだけど
だから私がイメージして喋ってるものが子供が理解すると思いますか？違います
子供のバージョンが別なんです
そういうわけで 発信するバージョンと受信するバージョンが相当変わるんです
はい これでもう 半分が終わりました
あのテーマは本当によく分析しなきゃね
難しいテーマなんです
で